first of all i have to ask you how's the
puppy
he's good he's not here at the moment
usually he's with me but he's good he's
just um
he bites everything he's like it's like
really like
you gotta watch them a lot
certainly do yeah we got one too not too
long ago and it's uh
it's a full-on thing it's a full thing
all right let's talk about the album
congratulations
thank you sounds like relationship
material from the get-go how did your
own relationship shape and
influence the material this time around
on the album
um i think i mean in a million different
ways but i think
besides the context and the concepts of
the actual songs um
camilla was with me during the whole
process so i really had someone
who was kind of by my side pushing me to
stick with my ideas because
the interesting thing about being an
artist i feel like is there's always
these moments of self-doubt that
kind of make you feel like you want to
just throw it all away
um that make you forget the excitement
you had when you first came up with the
original concept
and she was always there to push me
through those moments and uh
yeah i mean it really that is like a
super power seriously i think having
someone
be by your side to be able to be like no
you're on to something don't don't don't
get discouraged keep going
um so yeah i kind of i owe that to her a
lot
i love that so she was like your litmus
test throughout that's great
yeah she was really pushing that's great
so the song
24 hours on the album is talking about
taking the plunge and moving in with
that special someone
full-time i loved it it got caught in my
head is this foreshadowing for a new
house
yeah and we we've been looking for a
house for a while but i think
with uh kovit and everything we've just
been spending time with family
um which is also really nice so um
yeah it'll happen one day there's no
rush but we're definitely searching
whether it's in miami or toronto i'm not
sure yet
i'd say toronto i'm just saying you'd
say
i just feel like you may be potentially
a little biased
maybe a little bit maybe a little bit um
so when when you're singing about
relationships on the song
and and and then you flip and you talk
about sort of the dark side of fame
when did the glitz and the glam sort of
start to lose its shine for you
from time to time and when when did that
dark side did you recognize it for the
first time
i think the truth about any any industry
or anything in life is there's always a
dark and
the light side and um you you
no matter what you're doing you're never
gonna have just light um
so for me it's always been there
and present i think that nowadays i find
that there's just certain aspects of it
that i'm just not interested in
and i'm just not willing to compromise
about and you know
i think that's like what monster is
writing is about in this in some sort of
way is like you know
about society putting celebrities up on
a pedestal and then
tearing them down off the pedestal but
the interesting thing about that
actually is that as time goes on it
feels like the more we get
uh become one with instagram and twitter
and social media
every single person is up on this social
media pedestal
of these expectations of a perfect life
and um i don't think anyone ever
realized what that felt like except for
celebrities 50 years ago but nowadays i
feel like everybody knows in some sort
of small way what it feels like to be a
mini celebrity because of
social media and it's exhausting and i
think the the point of the song was like
look if we trip and fall
this doesn't make you a monster this
makes you absolutely the opposite it
makes you human it makes you exactly
what
it is to be human which is to mess up
and learn um
and uh that's the point i think i was
really trying to make more than
my life you know right i think you know
i remember meeting you at our uh new
year's eve show
many many years ago that we did up in
niagara falls where we all froze
but i've seen you a couple times since
then and you're one of the very few that
i can say has
it really feels like you've stayed true
to who you are what do you
think who do you or what do you
attribute that to i mean
you showed on your documentary you have
an incredible family
exactly yeah i mean i i really do
believe your support system is
everything and
you're you know my ability to be able to
express my feelings and live in those
feelings is the reason that i can
process them and get through them um and
i have people who are there for me
no matter what and from friends
to the people i work with to my my mom
and dad it's like there's constant
support and that is
really what will get you through hard
times
yeah with with monster with justin
bieber i know he was your idol for so
many years what was it like
in being in the recording studio finally
with him
it was um it was super normal at first
and then i think i might have had two
to five minutes of like shock and pure
disbelief
and um i mean he's just so talented and
so
kind and so gracious and so amazing to
be around
um so i yeah i mean
it was just it's just been a really
amazing experience being able to work
with him and also
more than that being able to become
friends and kind of connect on a deeper
level than just
a song you know that's so nice so
between the two of you who's more
critical of their own work
would it be you doing it doing a line
over and over again or would it be
in doing a line over and over again i
don't really know i
i don't know to be honest but i know i'm
really critical that's what i can that's
what i can say
okay all right um
you we really got to see a side of your
personal life
in the documentary and wonder and you
know i want to thank you for showing
sort of that
emotional side where you know real men
cry real men have that little kid
in them who question their actions um
why was it so important for you to sort
of break that toxic
masculinity stereotype
because i think it's for me has been
something that has
caused me the most amount of anxiety and
it's the
feeling of having to be so strong all
the time and having to
be bigger or better than feeling
sad or feeling anxious or feeling you
know upset
and real strength comes from
being strong enough and being vulnerable
enough to feel those feelings and to cry
until and to let it go and i mean
the truth about it is if if any guy is
like
cringing at those words that means they
need it even more
it's like it's true and and it's
something that
you only can experience once you've kind
of pushed yourself to do those things
um i mean the toughest guys in the world
will say they feel better after a good
cry and it's just the truth
about life and no matter of your man or
a woman it's just it's just human nature
and i think um
for me it's it's about breaking down i
think stereotypes
but more so it's just about being
completely honest with
the things that have helped me in my
life and if there's any
other people out there who who feel like
they need some of that then to be
inspired by it you know
yeah let me tell you women have been
saying a good cry feels like a really
good thing for a long time
oh i know and that's and that's a huge
part of the problem i mean the
interesting thing about vulnerability is
that i when i started first dating my
girlfriend
i i used to um praise myself for being
such a vulnerable
open guy right and you don't i didn't
realize how
much i was holding in until i started to
date somebody and i was like oh my god i
really could i really don't want to tell
her that i'm feeling
weak or like there's a another layer
it's like an onion you just keep peeling
back layers and layers and layers and
women are worlds ahead of us so we just
we'll catch up maybe one day but we're
trying you know yeah well when you have
a good partner
you start to hit that sweet spot and
that's what happens it's true
it's true well thank you so much for the
time appreciate it can't wait for you to
get home to toronto
thanks back to pickering yes safe
travels
see ya you too okay bye
you